i know that you guys are like family
over there i know all of you ladies
um so when tamara decides you know that
she's no longer gonna be a part of the
show what's that process like
like saying goodbye to her i think
naturally it's bittersweet we're like
man we we love having you but at the
same time when you're genuinely
someone's friend
you know what makes them happy and i
know that being with her children
and being in nappa with her husband and
running their business there and
all the other opportunities and the
dreams that she still wants to fulfill
as a friend we're like girl yes like you
got this we know that
this next journey the next steps that
she's going to take are going to be
phenomenal and we're excited to see
those happen those dreams come true for
her so
um again we're like damn we gonna miss
you tam
that rhymed but we're also just so proud
of her and so happy for her in real life
yeah yeah for sure and then you get this
like
boss of a woman in garcelle beauvais
coming in
oh those are fighting words for me that
is some white people stuff
how has that been have you guys
connected already like with the process
okay
we've been zooming it up um and we
actually start
this following week and i'm super
excited i think that
um having a new person just at the table
so to speak even though
we'll be in our homes but um it will
definitely bring a new dynamic to the
show but i think
that's what we're excited for we're
excited for new conversations
a new personality in those conversations
and um
i have so many questions for garcia i
mean there's so much about her that we
don't know and that we're so excited to
discover
well the first thing you know everybody
at home is asking are you guys taking
her away from real housewives in beverly
hills
ah i do not believe so okay
okay we like that we want her to play
double duty no
we right we like that melon and magic on
beverly hills
yeah we definitely do and and the other
thing
um you know we're excited because genie
mai is going to be we just talked to her
yesterday
on dancing with the stars so how excited
are
you uh to see her get down she said she
always thought she was a good dancer
because she could dance in the club
but she realized quickly she was not i'm
in the middle of the dance floor
sometimes i shut down the dance floor
totally different story here no i think
she's an amazing dancer and i think she
what jeannie's gonna bring to that
competition is not just dancing but
people are gonna fall in love with her
spirit
they're gonna fall in love with her
personality she has so much sass
and she's hysterical i just think she's
going to do an amazing job and she's a
hard
worker so i think that for whatever she
lacks in talent she will make up in hard
work so i
cannot wait to see my girl get out there
i love the thing
i like the whole thing that's your bet
right
the whole 100 on genie my winning
dancing with the stars
we need as many clues as we can can you
guess who's a bad singer
i think she's gonna bring it without
hearing a single note
no way someone in a shirt that awful
wouldn't think like an angel
i'm obsessed with all things singing
shows first of all so there's a panel
and then they but the contestants don't
know so so
break it down for me okay ken jung is
the host
he hangs out with a contestant who has a
chance to win a hundred
thousand dollars there is a panelist
there are panelists it's five of us over
here me
cheryl guess and a musical
celebrity who at the end is going to
duet with whoever is the last
good singer or bad singer standing
whoever is left
they have to do it with this celebrity
singer we've had bob and dick jordan
sparks
so many amazing singers so now there's
six
secret voices and from those six secret
voices some are good singers some are
bad singers
it's never an exact number of like how
many
and every challenge they have to guess
just based on their look or lip sync
challenge or a whisper
if they are a good singer or a bad
[Applause]
singer
you